hola yo soy jaime riquelme doctor en paz
y seguridad internacional
me dedico desde hace más de 20 años a
estudiar metódicamente el liderazgo como
factor de la resolución de problemas
sociales y organizacionales en esta
ocasión les vengo a presentar la charla
el liderazgo como factor del desarrollo
de una sociedad
sabías tú que méxico y chile son
sociedades verticales y que esa podría
ser la principal razón que nos impide
como países alcanzar el desarrollo
la verticalidad en términos prácticos es
imponerle a una persona sin que tenga
elección el qué y el cómo solucionar un
problema que le afecta
podemos sentirla cada vez que alguien
nos dice haz esto y nada más
la sociedad es mexicana y chilena por
nombrar dos ejemplos y en general
latinoamérica son sociedades de alta
distancia de poder colectivistas e
intolerantes a la incertidumbre donde la
jerarquía los grupos y el dogma imponen
la iniciativa las decisiones y las
relaciones de las personas
en estas sociedades se levantan barreras
de verticalidad social económica y
política que impiden constantemente a
las personas solucionar sus problemas
más relevantes
estudios de base científica demuestran
que en latinoamérica somos bastante más
intolerantes a la incertidumbre más del
doble de distantes de poder y casi el
triple de colectivistas que los países
más desarrollados del mundo la idea que
quiero enseñarte es que el liderazgo es
la clave para el bienestar sostenible de
una sociedad y para la autorrealización
de las personas de niño fui formaban una
familia vertical donde la disciplina y
la autoridad eran la expresión del amor
a los 17 años entre el ejército y fui un
oficial de infantería por más de 20 años
mis primeras experiencias me enseñaron
que el autoritarismo es decir se hace lo
que yo digo y nada más
solucionaba el problema en forma
inmediata pero en el largo plazo se
generaba gran dependencia en las
personas y si yo no estaba presente nada
resultaba
aprendí lo importante que es la
autonomía y el empoderamiento de las
personas la efectividad y la inspiración
en ellos era sorprendente hoy y desde
hace 10 años me dedico a investigar y
enseñar liderazgo a estudiantes y
trabajadores
el liderazgo es el arte de resolver
problemas relevantes con una actuación
armonizada de grupos humanos
los líderes que ejercen liderazgo son
personas que acostumbran a contribuir a
la solución de problemas relevantes sin
violencia sin autoritarismo sin
descalificaciones y sin expresiones como
yo bueno tómalo yo sabio tú ignorante yo
gano tú pierdes los líderes que ejercen
liderazgo comprenden que los problemas
relevantes son complejos y que todos
sabemos y al mismo tiempo ignoramos
parte de la solución es por esta razón
que estos líderes son inclusivos a la
hora de invitar a todas las personas a
solucionar un problema y al mismo tiempo
desafiantes e intelectualmente para que
a partir de dicha diversidad surjan
ideas creativas y efectivas en la
solución de los problemas
en esto de querer solucionar un problema
relevante como por ejemplo la pobreza
surge la inequidad propia de un
bienestar que es insostenible esta
inequidad como diría que en green es un
problema perverso y puede ser resuelto
con horizontalidad ahora bien que es en
términos prácticos la horizontalidad
en términos prácticos la horizontalidad
es aquel modelo social que favorece la
autonomía el respeto y la colaboración
entre las personas a diferencia de la
verticalidad que favorece la obediencia
la subestimación y la competencia
la horizontalidad se puede distinguir
claramente de la verticalidad
la vertical y ad se organiza en
jerarquías y la horizontalidad enredar
kias si quisiéramos distinguirlas en las
relaciones interpersonales podemos
encontrar expresiones como de la madre
al hijo haz esto en vez de haz lo que
estimes del grupo de amigos al joven es
que todos lo hacemos en lugar de es tu
decisión del profesor el estudiante
estás equivocado en vez de está seguro
de lo que dices todas estas expresiones
dan cuenta de una verticalidad que se
refleja en la distancia de poder el
colectivismo y la intolerancia a la
incertidumbre
los países cuyo bienestar es sostenible
es decir perduran en el tiempo y el
espacio tienen economías prósperas a
altos niveles de desarrollo humano y
simultáneamente altos niveles de equidad
dicho bienestar es para todas las
personas
para comprender el liderazgo en una
sociedad es necesario analizar la
cultura en cuanto a cómo las personas
toman decisiones y se relacionan
la distancia de poder el colectivismo y
la intolerancia de incertidumbre son
dimensiones culturales que según git
hogstedt explican en parte cómo son las
sociedades en los diferentes países
la distancia de poder se define como la
resignación a las diferencias de poder
en una sociedad y puede ser reconocida
por la expresión de esto a mayor
distancia de poder es probable que
estemos esperando a una autoridad formal
para hacer o no hacer esto explica el
porqué a muchas personas nos cuesta
tomar las iniciativas somos pasivos poco
participativos y nos mantenemos a la
espera de que un tercero solucionen los
problemas relevantes el colectivismo se
entiende como la preferencia por la
conducta grupal la que puede reconocerse
por la expresión es que todos lo hacen a
mayor colectivismo es probable que los
grupos más cercanos exijan lealtad y que
la persona decida por ellos más que por
sí misma esto explica el porqué si el
grupo está de acuerdo o en desacuerdo en
algo nosotros también lo estamos sin
pensar críticamente dicha posición
la intolerancia a la incertidumbre
entendida como la amenaza percibida ante
lo desconocido puede ser reconocida por
frases como estas equivocado
a mayor evitación de incertidumbre es
probable que el dogma determine la
interpretación de los hechos sin dejar
espacio a dudas ni cuestionamientos esto
explica el porqué nos cuesta tanto la
innovación la creatividad la
investigación el desarrollo científico y
tecnológico y es por qué tachamos de
conflictivos a los pensadores críticos
las diferencias culturales entre los
países más desarrollados del mundo y los
países latinoamericanos son enormes los
estudios demuestran que nuestro modelo
social es vertical y que esta
verticalidad puede ser la causa de las
fallas de la institucionalidad de la
ineficiencia del modelo económico y de
los conflictos sociales en méxico o
chile y en general en latinoamérica
bueno y qué pasa con el liderazgo
el liderazgo según en un hollander es un
proceso de interacciones entre un líder
los colaboradores y una situación que
afecta a todos
por ejemplo la inequidad y la necesidad
de un bienestar sostenible el liderazgo
está al centro de esta interacción
en las sociedades con alta distancia de
poder se enfatiza el rol del líder como
la pieza fundamental del puzzle el
liderazgo en las de alto colectivismo se
resalta el grupo y en las de alta
intolerancia e incertidumbre se prioriza
el dogma ninguna de las tres dimensiones
es la clave sino que las tres son
relevantes en su interacción más cercana
mientras más baja es la distancia de
poder el colectivismo y la evitación
incertidumbre más relevante es la
interacción entre el líder los
colaboradores y la situación y más
liderazgo hay en la sociedad
en méxico en chile y en general en
latinoamérica se tiende a valorar más el
rol del líder de los colaboradores o de
la situación sin enfatizar la
interacción entre estos tres elementos
en el gráfico se puede apreciar el gran
tamaño de los triángulos y su lejanía
del centro es decir del liderazgo en
cambio en los países más desarrollados
del mundo la mayoría nórdicos con
excepción de nueva zelanda la
integración de estos tres elementos es
mayor en el gráfico se puede apreciar
triángulos más pequeños y una mayor
cercanía al centro es decir al liderazgo
las sociedades más desarrolladas del
mundo donde el bienestar es sostenible
están basadas en el liderazgo y las
sociedades aún no desarrolladas donde el
bienestar es insostenible como
latinoamérica en autoridad
necesitamos una transformación cultural
hacia una sociedad más horizontal para
ello se hace necesario promover la
colaboración
más que la competencia para que los
problemas de mayor complejidad como la
inequidad y la necesidad de un bienestar
sostenible puedan ser comprendidos
adecuadamente y tratados con efectividad
por la mayor cantidad de personas es
imprescindible que promovamos el respeto
más que la subestimación para que
mediante interacciones armonizadas todas
las personas sus opiniones sus creencias
y sus ideas más que toleradas sean
valoradas
es urgente que potenciamos la autonomía
más que la obediencia para que las
personas se atrevan a tomar iniciativas
sin esperar que un tercero como la
autoridad política económica o social
defina el que ella el cómo solucionar
los problemas relevantes los países más
desarrollados del mundo son menos
verticales menos colectivistas y más
tolerantes a la incertidumbre
latinoamérica en general es todo lo
contrario y por esa razón es que existen
barreras de verticalidad infranqueables
que favorecen la jerarquía los grupos y
los dogmas y que impiden que las
personas comunes ejercemos liderazgo
logremos un bienestar sostenible y la
autorrealización que tanto anhelamos
para solucionar este problema es
necesario una transformación cultural
hacia una sociedad más horizontal
el liderazgo es la clave para el
bienestar sostenible en una sociedad
para superar la inequidad y para
favorecer la autorrealización de las
personas
para que todas las personas puedan
ejercerlo necesitamos uno promover una
cultura más horizontal 2 potenciar la
autonomía el respeto y la colaboración
entre las personas y 3 reducir las
barreras políticas económicas y sociales
que dificultan el ejercicio del
liderazgo es decir todo aquello que
impida que las personas puedan
participar de manera armonizada en la
solución de los problemas relevantes de
su vida de sus comunidades y de la
sociedad en su totalidad resolver la
pobreza y la inequidad está en nuestras
manos y el liderazgo es una extra
principal herramienta
hasta luego
[Música]